hello there I'm calf I'm Dan we're the
slow mo guys back when we first started
this channel Dan before we really knew
what it was all about we used to do a
lot more challenges we did like
competitions between us yeah yeah why
don't we first one go back to our roots
so you can shoot this candle out I think
I've got an advantage here cuz you shoot
guns and I don't yeah and you're scared
of them I've seen you try what's the
what's the penalty for losing football
to the head supposed oh yeah I'll get my
revenge it will be shooting this on the
Frenchman's be 25 11 at 28,000 frames a
second I'm going to position the camera
behind the candle just to prolong the
amount of time that the pellet is on
screen because there it's still most 3/5
yeah
okay that probably to stay lit yeah it's
Chloe
just an inch off that's a good first try
I was like no way because I saw the
flame girl and the candle move I was
like you put it I just blasted straight
through the wick by the looks of it
there's a blast it can work out the way
I don't know maybe mr. wick is that wind
I don't think that's a win okay so it
has to hit the actual top bit here you
could say that shot was wicked yeah got
it oh oh so close I think I was so close
so close I can almost feel the
satisfaction of robbing a football in it
damn it you're getting closer I am maybe
you didn't even go anywhere near it oh
so close
goodness me lucky escape that was very
close
happy with that dammit what I had it so
right
Oh No
yeah
Oh No that's it yeah the again just
keeps laughing that bit Oh see if that
was a premature celebration eyes count
come on accounts let's go
but the week went fine look okay the
wick we bend and move what happened was
as you hit the wax which saw shockwave
wax we check main weaken quick well I'm
not gonna give that to you it's just do
you want to see it a shot where we hid
the wick as the winning shot it's up to
you you can take the win on that if you
think you deserve it I mean I absolutely
deserve it yeah but all right how about
this we'll keep going yeah of us hit the
wick will trump that victory if not you
were okay that's the deal the underneath
with
oh you've got it you're pretty good yeah
you freight to wit you actually hit the
wig look at the wig that's been hit
around the tip as well and the tear
no they always religions that thing
you know I actually feel like a section
with that just because yours was good
but that was so good so we're shooting
against this fence which thankfully
there's nothing behind the other side
apart from trees so that they went
through one of them went through good
you can see if you look through this one
as a whole what actually goes through
yeah this why don't you can see the
pellet is stuck in that stuff weird over
here over here one here not the best
grouping big actually yeah well this is
these are clearly my shots okay yeah
your ones are like that one there that
one there you know not such a good one
over there probably yeah yeah some such
satisfying shots from that that close up
Chris so Chris love it I can't believe I
won I'm rubbish devastated I've actually
good because not only did I lose against
you I also have a lot on my face again
but this time with this camera so 28,000
FPS it was a mouse that last time any
excuse
goodness sake hopefully you enjoyed that
little challenge I think we should do
more of those I did not do it yeah you
usually do not on camera though no one
cares about you know feel free to follow
us on Twitter
definitely watch some videos on our
second channel there pretty top and uh
subscribe bye t-shirt my t-shirt my
opposed step step hop Catalan [ __ ] it
one butcher Roden Oakland those are it
what to up before I leave you I recently
did a collaboration which is something I
hardly ever do but it's one of my
favorite channels in the whole of
YouTube corridor digital we made a
fallout 4 themed video lots of slow-mo
and lots of me running around like a
fool so be sure to check it out right
here
yeah